[Musique]
la différence est spectaculaire car le
maître et son chien peuvent aller
jusqu'à 50 km heure
[Musique]
ce binôme six complices c'est tout ni
presles 36 ans et oslo 3 ans
ensemble ils ont conquis en 2021 le
titre de champion de france de bike
goring où canivtt une discipline dérivée
d'une machine ou le traîneau est
remplacé par le vélo mais le pilote
reste très actif le vététiste et les
actifs même doublement actifs ne
serait-ce que déjà pour aller pour
avancer mais aussi pour prêter attention
à son chien pour donner des directions
pour veiller à ne pas à ne pas commettre
d'erreur alors l'entente entre les deux
est impérative
c'est à dire que le chien est attelé à
nous atteler au vélo il faut qu'il y ait
une harmonie parce que l'on peut pas se
permettre d'aller à des vitesses assez
élevé en sachant en donnant pas toute
notre confiance aux chiens imaginez-vous
en pleine ligne droite il devait partir
d'un seul coup à droite ce serait
vraiment trop dangereux on prend pas des
dégâts mail à tout voir
après les efforts intenses direction le
lac de ce poids à l'eva alemanno mais
méfiez vous des apparences oslo nalia et
m'a dit sont toujours en train de
travailler là quand je fais ça par
exemple je vais je vais travailler leur
leur patience leur écoute sont focalisés
sur moi quand je leur demande de partir
ils partent et en fin de compte ils vont
travailler énormément la musculation et
moyennes armement travail et ils s'en
rendent pas compte parce que pour eux
c'est un jeu
il faut que ça reste un jeu de toute
façon la base c'est le le plaisir si y'a
pas de plaisir il y aura plus de
performances
donc là ils sont calmes j'y vais ok
[Applaudissements]
ayvaz new way man anneaux les trois
chiens de tony prennent sont de la race
des crises terre ils ont entre 3 et 4
ans mais pas question de commencer le
canidé t'es trop con
je les laisse grandir un chien de cette
grandeur là s'est il est adulte environ
à 12 mois 12 13 mois leur cartilage leur
squelette commence à être être bien
formé donc en général je commence à
mettre le harnais
après douze mois au quotidien tenez
s'occupe beaucoup de ses partenaires sur
pattes mais il ne délaisse pas son
propre entraînement
il a commencé le cani vtt en 2015 pour
faire une activité avec son chien ce
lien qui nous unit c'est vraiment unique
le dépassement de soi c'est en fin de
compte quand on est fatigué ou qu'on n'a
pas envie d'y aller parce qu'il pleut
parce que on le fait pour notre chien
parce que lui veut sortir veux courir
veut s'amuser donc du coup c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'elle partage vraiment avec avec notre
animal
partenaires sportifs compagnon de vie
tony et ses chiens sont très liés il
pratique le cani vtt dans l'un des dix
clubs que compte la région centre val de
loire
[Musique]